[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 300 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
ينددوا بعداء الغرب ويناور بمعاهده نيو
ستارت يضغط على الجرح سنجعل اقوى كيان
بالعالم
وقبيله ايام من ذكرى انطلاقه الحرب روسيا
امام تحدي صراع العسكريين واوكرانيا تتلمس
وعودا غربيه لم تنفذ
رعب في جنوب تركيا من ارض تولد الزلازل
وخبراء يحذرون البناء في الموقع نفسه
وبالطريقه نفسها سيعيد الكارثه
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا
المانيا تتوعد ايران بعد الحكم باعدام
مواطن يحمل جنسيتها وبلينكن يرمي كره
احياء الاتفاق نووي بملعب طهران
[موسيقى]
انه قوي لكنه واجه اراده الولايات المتحده
الحديديه هكذا وصف الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ومغامرته بالهجوم على اوكرانيا بايدن تعهد
من وارسو والحليف الوثيق في عمليه التصدي
للهجوم الروسي بالا تنتصر روسيا ابدا في
الحرب بل ونكى الجرح الذي ما يزال يؤلم
روسيا الا وهو حلف الناتو اتعهد بايدن
بعقد قمه للحلف في واشنطن لجعله اقوى كيان
في العالم
كيف ما تزال صامده وتشعر بالفخر والكبرياء
والاهم انها ما تزال حره
عندما قامت روسيا بشن عملها العدائي كان
العالم قد اجتمع ليعيش اختبارا اوروبا
والناتو والولايات المتحده وكافه
الديمقراطيات استجابتنا ابتسمت بالوحده
واظهرنا مدى وحدتنا وقوتنا للعالم
[موسيقى]
الرئيس بوتين اطلق دباباته لتجوب مناطق
مختلفه من اوكرانيا وكان مخطئا في هذا
القرار الشعب الاوكراني يتحلى بقدر كبير
من الشجاعه الناتو والدول الاوروبيه
اتحدوا في مواقفهم بدعم اوكرانيا واستطاعت
القوات الاوكرانيه ان تحرق الدبابات
الروسيه الناتو ولد من رحم الوحده
تصريحات بايدن اتت بعد خطاب اعلن فيه
تعليق مشاركه بلاده في معاهده نيو ستارت
بشان النزع السلاح النووي وامر فيه قواته
بالاستعداد لتجارب نوويه الخبر العاجل قبل
قليل عن مجلس الدوما بوتين قدم مشروع
قانون لتعليق العمل بمعاهده وسنصدر قرارا
فوريا غدا الخارجيه الروسيه امتصت صدمه
اعلان بوتين باعلان لاحق عن ان موسكو
ستستمر في احترام مستويات ترسانتها
النوويه بموجب المعاهده لكن رسائل بوتين
لم تقتصر على نيو ستارت اذ اكد الاستمرار
في تطوير العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
واتهم الغرب بالسعي لتدمير روسيا وبانه لم
يترك لها خيارا غير القيام بعمليتها بوتين
اتهم الغرب كذلك برفض الضمانات الامنيه
التي طلبتها بلاده وقال ان واشنطن قام
باعداد اوكرانيا لحرب طويله الامد
الناتو يضم دولا ذات ترسانه نوويه ليس فقط
في الولايات المتحده بل كذلك في بريطانيا
وفرنسا وجميعها موجهه ضد روسيا يجب ان نضع
ذلك في الاعتبار في الظرف الراهن لذلك
روسيا ستعلق مشاركتها في معاهده الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه واذا قامت الولايه
المتحده باجراء تجارب نوويه فنحن سنقوم
بالمثل اي حديث عن الاخلال بنظام الردع
النووي غير صحيح
من كيف معنا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل من
وارسو معنا مفرد العربيه حسين قنيبر من
موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمه اهلا بكم
جميعا ونحاول ان نتعرف على اصداء الخطابين
خطاب بوتين وخطاب بايدن كذلك وابدا من
موسكو مع كاتيا طعمه
مرحبا طاهر بالفعل كانت اليوم كلمه الرئيس
الروسيه التي وجهها الى الجمعيه
الفيدراليه كانت
بخصصها بالمجمل للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه
التي بداتها موسكو في اوكرانيا طبعا هو
بررر موقف موسكو من بدء العمليه العسكريه
وهو ما طبعا دفعه الغرب كما تحدث الى بدء
هذه العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا اما
طبعا
الشيء الرئيسي الذي تحدث فيه الرئيس
الروسي هو الى الشارع الروسي طبعا تحدث عن
الوضع الاقتصادي لروسيا والتماسك
الاقتصادي على الرغم من العقوبات
المتتاليه التي فرضتها او فرضتها الغرب
على موسكو نتيجه العمليه العسكريه تحدث
طبعا لطمانه الشارع الروسي حول عدم انهيار
او تماسك الاقتصاد على الرغم من هذا الضغط
الكبير على على موسكو من جانب من جانب اخر
طبعا هو
اعلن تعليق العمل بمعاهده ستارت كما تحدث
واكد انه لم يوقف هبل علق العمل بها كما
قال ان واشنطن دفعت موسكو الى التعليق هذه
المعاهده كان من قبل وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه
مرارا تحدث عن ان موسكو تمنع من دخول
المفتشين الى
المواقع الاستراتيجيه الروسيه بسبب ايضا
عدم امكانيه تفتيش المواقع الاستراتيجيه
في الولايات المتحده من قبل الجانب الروسي
طاهر الكلمه الحذيفه عادل الان حول اصداء
الكلمتين ايضا حذيفه
تحياتي طاهره يعني اذا سمحت لي ان ابدا
الخطاب بوتين قبل فقد علق مستشار الرئيس
فلاديمير زيلينسكي على خطاب بوتين وقال ان
يعني الخطاب اتى مرتبطا وانا الرئيس بوتين
كان مرتبكا وان الرئيس بوتين هو الشخص
الوحيد الذي لا يحق له الحديث عن القوانين
الدوليه باعتبار ان الاتحاد الروسي يخلق
جميع هذه الاعراف والقوانين الدوليه بحربه
على اوكرانيا وفي الجرائم والفضائع كما
وصفها التي يرتكبها الجيش الروسي في
اوكرانيا وقال ان الان هنالك شكل يعني
هنالك اهداف واضحه بالنسبه للاتحاد الروسي
لجعل هذه الحرب حرب طويله الامد ولكن قبل
ذلك يريد ان يسيطر على كامل الاراضي التي
ضمها بالفعل او يعني اراد ضم هذه المناطق
وبعد ذلك التحول الى حرب طويله الامد وحرب
استنزاف ولكن لديها اهداف مختلفه تماما
وهي استعاده السيطره لذلك يحتاج الى
الدبابات ويحتاج الى صواريخ بعيده المدى
اما بخصوص خطاب بايدي فلم يكن هنالك تعليق
بعد الخطاب ولكن كان هنالك تعليق في
الامور المتعلقه باوكرانيا التي ذكرها في
خطاب الاخير والتي اكد عليها في زيارته
الى كييفا المتعلقه بمواصله الدعم لاكييف
هذا ما شكره عليه القاده الاوكرانيون
ابتداء من الرئيسكي وكذلك مستشاري ووزير
خارجيته بعد ان وصف وهذه الزياره
بالتاريخيه واكدوا على ان الدعم مستمر من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طاهر حسين
قنيبر
مساء الخير يا طاهر الكلام الرئيس
الامريكي الذي يزور وارسو للمره الثانيه
خلال اقل من عام كلامه من هنا والذي انتهى
قبل ساعتين هنا في القلعه الملكيه في
اوارسو اثر كثيرا في نفوس المئات من
البولنديين الذين حضروا الخطاب صفقوا له
طويلا عندما قال ان بوتين سيخسر وان
اوكرانيا لن تكون ابدا نصرا روسيا
فالوحشيه لن تفوز اكثر من عشرين مره ذكر
بايدن كلمه حريه وقال قبل عام كنا نخشى من
سقوطك اكياد التي اتيت منها للتو اليوم
قويه وفخوره وحره قال ان بلاده ستفرض مع
شركائها الاوروبيين عقوبات جديده على
روسيا واعتبر ان وقف روسيا غزوها
لاوكرانيا
سينهي الحرب ووقف يا مقاومتها لروسيا
سينهي اوكرانيا حسب تعبير الرئيس الامريكي
الذي اعتبر ان حلف الناتو هو اكثر حلف
مترابط في العالم وهو اليوم اقوى من اي
وقت مضى وارسو للمفارقه الطاهر التي كان
اسم الحلف الذي ارتبط باسمها مرادفا
للكتله الشرقيه المؤيده للاتحاد السوفياتي
السابق كما تعلم حلف وارسو الذي كان خصما
لحلف النيتو اصبحت وارسو اليوم مدخلا لحلف
الناتو وهي المعبر للمساعدات العسكريه
والانسانيه الدوليه الى اوكرانيا اصبحت
راسها حربته حسين قنيبر شكرا جزيلا على
تغطيه هذا الخطاب التاريخي لبايدن في
وارسو وبخصوص كاتيا وحذيفه يبقيان معنا
لنتحدث عن ابرز التحديات في كلا البلدين
في الفقراء المقبله شكرا لكم جميعا
قبل بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه قام
الغرب بنقل الاسلحه الى النظام في
اوكرانيا من الدفاع الجوي وغيره من
الاسلحه الثقيله حتى انهم حاولوا ان
يقدموا لهذا النظام اسلحه نوويه
اليوم اعلن ان الدعم الذي سنقدمه
لاوكرانيا سيتضمن ذخائر واسلحه من نوع هاي
مارس وجافلين ورادارات للمراقبه لحمايه
المواطنين الاوكرانيين من القصف الجوي
هناك تغييرات جذريه تحدث في العالم اجمع
واحداث تاريخيه تحدد مستقبل بلدنا وشعبنا
وعلى عاتق كل واحد منا مسؤوليه وللتخلص من
التهديدات التي جاءت من النازيين الجدد في
اوكرانيا منذ العام 2014 تم اتخاذ قرار
بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه العام الماضي
غزو بوتين فشل فقد الجيش الروسي نصف
الاراضي التي احتلها الشباب الروس
الموهوبون يهربون بعشرات ومئات الالاف ولا
يريدون العوده الى روسيا
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه ربما يقترب
مخزونها من الذخائر من النفاذ بحسب تقرير
لمجله نيوزويك المجله نقلت عن مؤسس
المجموعه
ان الجيش الروسي توقف عن تزويد مجموعته
بقذائف المدفعيه والسبب العلاقات المعقده
مع المسؤولين الروس ودون ان يحدد منهم
اضاف بريغوجين ان المسؤولين العسكريين
الروس يتجاهلون مطالبه بل وفرض قيودا
جديده على مشتريات المجموعه من الذخيره
كما اوقفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قدره
بريكوجين على تجنيد السجناء ومنعته من
استخدام مناطق تدريب تابعه للجيش كانت
قوات فاجنر لعبت دورا محوريا في الحرب في
اوكرانيا لكن يبدو انها بدات تفقد نفوذها
بسرعه خاصه مع استبدال عناصر من فاجنر
بقوات من الجيش على طول الخطوط الاماميه
في منطقه دنيا اليوم انتقد بريجوجين صراحه
وبالاسم و الدفاع الروسي السرقه ورئيس
هيئه الاركان العامه الروسيه وقال انهما
يحاولان تدمير قوته فيما قد يرقى للخيانه
العظمى هذه الانتقادات تاتي فيما تقاتل
قوات فاجنر منذ اسابيع عده في ضخموت دون
ان تتمكن من السيطره عليها رغم تقدمها
بشكل كبير في محيطها وقد اشارت مصادر
مطلعه سابقا الى ان الكرملين ابلغ عددا من
الاعلاميين الروس اضافه الى غيرهم طبعا
بتفادي الترويج لفاجنر لا سيما بعد ان بات
لا يمكن التنبؤ بافعال رئيسها
[موسيقى]
يصدر رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع امرا بعد
امر يمنع تقديم الذخيره لفاجنر ومساعدتها
في النقل الجوي جاءت المعلومات للتو تفيد
بانهم رفضوا حتى امدادنا بمجارف حتى لا
يتمكن الرجال من الحفر هناك ببساطه معارضه
مباشره ومستمره وهي ليست سوى محاوله
لتدمير داكنر يمكن ان يقارن هذا بالخيانه
العظمى الان عندما تقاتل فاغنر من اجل
باخموت وتفقد المئات من مقاتليها كل يوم
هذا احد التحديات التي تقف بوجه روسيا اما
في المقابل في معسكر الغرب لم تحصل
اوكرانيا بعد على اكثر من نصف المساعدات
التي وعدت بها الدول الغربيه بحسب تحليل
صحيفه
ديسمبر الماضي حصلت وزاره الماليه
الاوكرانيه على حوالي 32 مليار دولار من
اصل 67 مليارا وعدت بها الدول الغربيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالشراكه مع بنك
الاستثمار الاوروبي تعهد بتقديم 32 مليار
دولار لم يصل منها الى كييف سوى 19 مليار
دولار لكن الاتحاد ادخل اصلاحات على
اجراءات الدفع في نوفمبر الماضي واعدا
بمساعده ماليه منتظمه بمعدل مليار و600
مليون دولار شهريا بشكل عام وعند احتساب
حجم المساعدات العسكريه والانسانيه يتخلف
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن الولايات المتحده
التي تصدرت تزويد اوكرانيا باكبر قدر من
الذخيره والاسلحه الثقيله
[موسيقى]
نعود الى مراسلنا من كياف حذيفه عادل والى
مراسلتنا من موسكو كاتيا طعمي وابدا معك
لو نحاول ان نفهم منك اكثر طبيعه الجدل
الدائر في الداخل الروسي حول هذا التحدي
الذي يعتبر من اكبر التحديات في الداخل
الروسي في اطار الحرب على اوكرانيا وهو
الخلافات بين القيادات العسكريه تحديدا ان
كان من يخطط او من ينفذ او من يسلح
والعلاقه مع فاجنر بشكل اساسي كذلك
صحيح طاهر لا شك انه كان هناك
مرارا حديث في وسط وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
عن امكانيه وجود خلاف طبعا بين
رئيس شركه فاجنر الخاصه ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه التي ظهرت مرارا خلال الفتره
السابقه من خلال اما كانت عن طريق تصريحات
وجهها او انتقادات وجهها الى وزاره الدفاع
والى القاده قاده العمليه العسكريه هناك
وليس لوحده كان هناك طبعا دائما تضامنا من
قبل الرئيس الشيشاني مع تصريحات فارغنر
التي طبعا ايدها عن وجود هناك خلل في
تنفيذ الخطط من قبل القاء القوات الذين
القاده الذين تم استبدالهم فيما بعد من
قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كما شاهدنا في
وقت لاحق لتعود الان
من جديد تصريحات التي وجهها الى وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بانها لا تقوم بتزويد
قواته بالاسلحه الكافيه للاستمرار
بالمعركه على الارض كما تعلم طاهر ان
القوات الخاصه كما تحدثت مرارا هي التي
كانت في الفتره الاخيره تتقدم على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهي التي سيطرت على اكثر من
منطقه خلال الفتره والتي تسعى للسيطره على
بخ ايضا لذلك هناك انتقادات كبيره من قبل
حتى الان لم ترد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على
هذه الانتقادات التي خرجت طبعا من قبل
رئيس شركه خاصه الطاهر اما على الجانب
الاوكراني فالتحدي الاكبر كما قلنا هو عدم
وصول اكثر من نصف المساعدات التي وعدت بها
ونطلع اكثر على حقيقه الموقف الرسمي
والشعبي الاوكراني حيال ذلك منك حذيفه
عادل الان
نعم في الحقيقه طاهر اذا بدانا بالموقف
الشعبي فالشعب الاوكراني ممتع جدا من هذا
التاخير لوصول المساعدات العسكريه ولا
سيما الاسلحه الحاسمه في المعركه هنا
نتحدث عن الدبابات وصول الدبابات الان
اوكرانيا تحاول منذ فتره طويله جدا اقناع
الغرب
يعني تقديم هذه الدبابات ولكنهم اقتنعوا
مؤخرا
بتسليم هذه الدبابات ولذلك للجانب
الاوكراني كان جاهزا بشكل كامل ولا الوقت
في صالح الاوكرانيين في هذه المعركه من
الجانب الشعبي هم ممتحنون جدا ويعتقدون ان
هذه الاسلحه ستكون حاسمه خاصه في المعركه
القادمه التي يتجهز لها الجانبان ويحشد
لها الموارد للاوكرانيين يحاولون استعاده
طبعا الاراضي التي سيطره عليها
الامر الاكثر تعقيدا هو عمليه ادخال
الاسلحه ووصولها الى جبهات القتال تعلم ان
الروسي يراقبون الاجواء بشكل جيد جدا ايضا
تعلم ان في الحرب الاستخبارات على الارض
يعني تعمل بشكل نشط جدا لذلك كانت هنالك
حمله لو لاحظت طاهره في الفتره الماضيه
داخل القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لتطهير
القوات المسلحه من اي احتمال لوجود يعني
منسوبين او اشخاص قد تصل عن طريقهم
المعلومه الى الاتحاد الروسي عمليه ادخال
الاسلحه فيها تعقيد كبير ولكن ايضا من من
اكبر التعقيدات التي تواجه اوكرانيا الان
هي تدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين على استخدام
هذه الاسلحه بعد ان وافق الغرب على تقديم
هذه الاسلحه لذلك الان جاري عمليه التدريب
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك في
بريطانيا وقد اليوم الملك
يعني القوات الاوكرانيه التي تتدرب في
الاراضي البريطانيه وكذلك طبعا في ابولشا
لذلك
ينتظر الان ان تكتمل عمليه التدريب ثم بعد
ذلك يمكن ان يعود الجنود لاستخدام هذه
الاسلحه حذيفه كاتيا شكرا جزيلا لكما
اعلنت الخارجيه الروسيه استدعاء السفيره
الامريكيه بسبب ما وصفته بتورط الولايات
المتحده في النزاع وتوسيع نطاق انخراطها
فيه موسكو طلبه واشنطن باتخاذ خطوات لسحب
افراد وعتاد حلف الناتو من اوكرانيا لخفض
التصعيد كما طالبتها بعدم التدخل في اي
تحقيق موضوعي حول تفجير خط نوت ستريم
وتقديم تفسيرات لما لحق به
نقلت عن مصادر مطلعه ان الرئيس الصيني
يستعد للقاء بوتين في موسكو في غضون شهور
واضاف التقرير ان الاجتماع سيكون في اطار
مسعا لعقد محادثات سلام متعدده الاطراف
وسيسمح للصين بتكرار دعواتها لعدم استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
كانت الصين انتقدت ارسال واشنطن مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا واتهمتها بالتربح
من الازمه
الولايات المتحده هي اكبر مورد للاسلحه
الى ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا امس اعلنت
الولايات المتحده عن 500 مليون دولار
كمساعدات عسكريه لذلك يجعل البعض يتساءل
عما تنوي الولايات المتحده فعله من خلال
الادعاء الكاذب بان الصين تقدم اسلحه تدعي
الولايات المتحده انها تحافظ على السلام
لكنها في الواقع تكسب المال من الازمنه
اما الهند فقالت ان علاقاتها مع روسيا تظل
مستقره على الرغم من الاضطرابات الدوليه
بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا وزير الخارجيه
الهندي سوبرا مريم قال ان بلاده تتمتع
بعلاقه جيده مع القوه الكبرى باستثناء
الصين متهما اياها بانتهاك اتفاقيات اداره
الحدود واعتبر الوزير الهندي ان بلاده
اضطرت لنشر اكبر عدد من القوات على الحدود
في زمن السلم بسبب التوتر مع الصين
امين وعام حلف النيتو يانس عبر عن قلق
الحلف من ان تكون الصين تخطط لدعم روسيا
عسكريا
[موسيقى]
نحن قلقون بشكل متزايد من ان الصين ربما
تخطط لتقديم دعم مميت للحرب الروسيه فذلك
سيكون خطيرا على امننا وعلى العالم باسره
ويبدو ان القلق بات يتسرب اكثر واكثر
لاوروبا الشرقيه فالرئيس الاركان التشيكي
بات يرى ان احتمال الحرب مع روسيا لم يعد
مستحيلا واعتبر انه اذا اندلع صراع بين
الناتو وروسيا فان تشيكيا ستشارك منذ اول
دقيقه مطالبا بالاستعداد من الان
ذكرياته الماضيه وانعكاساتها على الحرب
الاوكرانيه دائما ما كانت حديثه بوتين هذه
المره سلطت لموندا الفرنسيه الضوء على
طفوله وشباب زيلينسكي مع الهيمنه
السوفيتيه على بلدته في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الاوكراني من الاتحاد السوفيتي ومن
ثم روسيا لم يكن يوما وليدا لحظه عداء بل
تراكم منذ الصغر زينسكي الرئيس لم يختلف
يوما عن الطفل مواقف عده رصدتها لوموندي
الفرنسيه عكس التاثير نشاه زلنسكي على
توجهاته وصراعه الدائري مع روسيا مرحله
الطفوله كان عمر الطالب زيلنسكي عشره
اعوام عام
1988 اثناء الاحتفال بثوره اكتوبر او
الثوره البلشفيه امر المعلم بوقوف الطلاب
في ساحه الشعله الابديه في بلدته ووفقا
الفرنسيه لا ينسى توبيخه مع زملائه بسبب
عدم كي الوشاح الاحمر لمنظمه الشباب
الشيوعي مرحله الشباب في شبابه اعتاد
زلنسكي على الاحتفال امام النصب التذكاري
للجنود الذين حرروا مدينته عام
1944 وفي عام 2023 لم يتغير النصب
التذكاري وظل الذكرى تحرير بلدته من
النظام الشيوعي ترافق مشواره من الفن الى
السياسه رمزيه مسقط راس زلنسكي مدينه
كريفيريخ كانت مركزا مهما للمجهود الحربي
ايام التحدي الجمهوريات السوفيتيه وظلت
كذلك الى اليوم فلم يعد زيلنسكي الى مسقط
راسه منذ بدء الحرب بسبب القصف المتواصل
عليها
لكل من الرئيسين الاوكراني والروسي مخزون
من ذكريات الماضي صور ضلت عالقه في
الاذهان وتظهر على السطح كل ما اشتدت حده
الصراع الروسي الاوكرانيه عن السمان
العربيه
فالعربيه 300 ايضا وزير الدفاع التركي
يؤكد مجددا لا نزوح من سوريا باتجاه
اراضينا بعد الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت اداره الكوارث
التركيه عن ارتفاع عدد قتلى الزلزاله الى
42 الفن و30010 اشخاص كان رئيس التركي رجب
تعهد مجددا خلال تفقده ولايه عثمانيه
بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن الخسائر الضخمه في
الارواح وباعاده الحياه للمناطق المدمره
خلال عامة
من جهته نفى وزير الدفاع التركي خالوصي
اكار وجود اي حركه لجوء من سوريا باتجاه
تركيا منذ وقوع الزلزال واكد اكار عقب
قيامه بجوله تفقديه في المناطق المتضرره
بمدينه انطاكيا ان اكثر من 20 الف سوري
عادوا الى بلادهم منذ وقوع الكارثه
نتابع من ادلب الان مع مراسل العربيه محمد
الاشقر اهلا بك محمد كيف هو الوضع الان في
ادلب
مع تكشف المزيد من الاضرار والخسائر لما
حصل في زلزال سادس من الشباط فبراير وما
حدث بالامس كذلك
انا ليس لدي صوت
نحاول نحاول مره اخرى مع محمد الاشقر
مراسل العربيه من ادلب عندما يجهز الاتصال
نعود اليه ان شاء الله وسنتحدث ايضا الى
مراسلنا من ادلب مسلم السيد عيسى ولكن
الان نتابع فيما لدينا في هذه النشره ف 15
يوما مرت على زلزال تركيا وسوريا والهزات
الارضيه الارتداديه ما زالت مستمره بشكل
دوري حتى الان لكن ربما تكون هذه هي
المشكله هل كان زلزالا واحدا وهل يمكن
اعتبار كل ما حدث مجرد توابع وهزات ارضيه
الثابت بحسب معهد المسح الجيولوجي
الامريكي ان ما حدث في السادس من فبراير
كان زلزالين مختلفي المركز والقوه الاول
في غازي عنتاب والثاني في قهرمان مرعش
وهذا ما ذهب اليه الرئيس التركي
حين اكد ان تركيا شهدت زلزالين وانهما
كانا بقوه القنابل الذريه
[موسيقى]
جميع علماء الزلازل اتفقوا على ان الزلزال
الاخير كان من اقوى الزلازل التي حدثت في
العالم وقدر قوته بقوه مئات القنابل
الذريه نحو 13 الف جريح يتماثلون للشفاء
في المستشفيات يعتبر حجم وشده الزلازل
ومدى تدميرها ظاهره طبيعيه
استثنائيه اتمنى الرحمه لكل القتلى الذين
يبلغ عددهم
35,418 من مواطني بلدي واتمنى شفاء
المصابين الذين تم انقاذهم الذين يبلغ
عددهم وخمسه الاف وخمسمائه وخمسه جرحى
وبالامس عاودت الارض التركيه الكره عدم
الاستقرار هذا ينذر ربما بكوارث اخرى
مقبله قد تكون تمهيدا لزلزال اكبر ما نشر
موجه من الرعب من الترقب خصوصا في تركيا
وسوريا فيوم امس المئات من السكان في
الدولهتين وايضا في لبنان افترشوا الساحات
العامه والشوارع خشيه سقوط المباني عليهم
مع تكرار الهزات الارضيه في تركيا دعت
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه المواطنين
وهي افاد دعتهم لتجنب دخول مساكنهم
المتضرره مع تواصل خطر الهزات الارتداديه
التي قد يتجاوز بعضها خمس درجات على مقياس
رختر لكن هل ما حدث في تركيا امر شائع
الزلزالان الكبيران اللذان ضربا تركيا
وسوريا قبل اسبوعين كان شديدين وكان من
المتوقع ان تتبعهما هزات ارتداديه ربما
تمتد لايام او لاس
وحدث الزلزالان من مركزين ومن فوالق
زلزاليه مختلفه وبفارق تسع ساعات فصلت
بينهما اما زلزال لا يوم امس فضرب الاول
محافظه هاتاي الاكثر تضررا من الزلزال
الكبير
واعقبه زلزال اخر بعد ثلاث دقائق ضرب
مدينه السويديه الساحليه بحسب اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه فماذا يحدث
عندما يضرب الزلزال وكيف ينتقل من مكان
لاخر ونركز هنا على تركيا وجوارها الزلازل
الماضيه حدثت في فالق شرق الاناضول وفي
صحف صفيحه الاناضول التي تحاذي الصفيحه
العربيه
وتتعامد على صدع البحر الميت
ولعدم اتصال الفوالق ببعضها بشكل مباشر
فعندما يحدث الزلزال يؤدي هذا لحدوث خلخله
في الفوالق المحيطه لينتقل الضغط من فالق
لاخر ما يقود لحركه غير اعتياديه للقشره
الارضيه هذا ضغط المتنقل من صفيحه ارضيه
الى اخرى يحدث العديد من الهزات
الارتداديه التي تستمر الى حين استقرار
الضغط بين الصفائح وتوقف حركه الفالق
ونتابع في الشرح بعد ان اثار الجدل
بتوقعاته في السادس من فبراير بتوقعاته
حول الزلزالين في السادس من فبراير عاد
العالم الهولندي فرانك هوجربيتس ليثير
الرعب فبعد زلزاليل امس غرد ليلفت النظر
نظر متابعيه الى تغريده سابقه له توقع
فيها حدوث زلازل جديده في المنطقه بين
العشرين والثاني والعشرين من فبراير اي
الان بل ان الذروه قد تكون غدا بحسب
توقعاته لكن
لم يعد بمفرده فكثير من علماء الزلازل
باتوا يتوقعون زلزالا هائلا قد يضرب
اسطنبول العاصمه الاقتصاديه لتركيا خلال
السنوات المقبله في فتره ربما لا تتجاوز
عام 2030
وجهه اخرى للزلازل تحدث عنها عالم الزلازل
التركيه ناجي جرور وقال ان الخشيه تسود من
ان تضرب زلازل اضنه وقبرص ودعا السلطات
تركيا الى عدم الاسراع في اعاده الاعمار
الا بعد فتره من الوقت بسبب استمرار توابع
الزلزال الصغيره والكبيره
ينضم الينا متابعه لهذا الموضوع الاستاذ
في علم الجيولوجيا سمير زعطيطي اهلا بك
معنا استاذ سمير في العربيه 360 وانا اريد
ان ابدا معك
باعاده الاسئله التي ذكرناها في الشرح
اولا الفرق بين الزلزال والهزه وكيف نميز
بين اذا يعني مكانه بالامس
هزات ارتداديه للزلزال الكبير او
زلزالا او زلزالين جديدين
يعني
الكلام الذي تفضلت فيه كتير مهم كثير مهم
ولكن
يعني ما هو مصدر الزلازل ليش ليش بتصير
زلازل
يتكلمون عن صفائح تتحرك طب ما الذي يحرك
هذه الصفائح الحركه تحتاج الى طاقه ما هي
الطاقه هون كل العلماء اللي عم بيحكوا
وبيحكوا على وجه الارض وبيحكوا على اشياء
ما الها علاقه باللي احنا اللي بنسميه
بالحرج الحركه الكوكب الداخليه حركه كوكب
الارض الداخليه او الجو ديناميك يعني
داخلي بالنسبه لسطح الارض هم يتكلمون عن
اشياء تحدث على سطح الارض
وهناك هناك فرق كبير يعني ما يحدث تحت تحت
سطح الارض لا علاقه له لا باقمار ولا
بالشمس ولا
بنجوم ولا بسدود ولا باي شيء هناك عالم
اخر تماما مختلف بدانا نكتشفه من منتصف
القرن الماضي كيف نستطيع ان نكتشف ما يوجد
في المركز الارض لا نستطيع الولوج مباشره
الى هناك اكبر اكبر بيئه اعمق كبير هو 12
كلم عملته بروسيه
كيف نعرف بطريقه غير مباشره هناك زلازل
تخترق الكره الارضيه من جهه الى الجهه
المقابله هذه الموجات الزلزاليه لانها
تخترق الصخور تختلف سرعاتها حسب انواع
الصخور التي تخترقها وهناك موجه زلزاليه
لا تسير في السوائل
تظهر بالمناطق الصلبه وتختفي
هناك هناك موجات تمر بالسوائل وبكل شيء
علم الزلازل تطور من خلال دراسات حتى
لتسجيلات زلزاليه قديمه اعيد النظر فيها
واعيد
يعني
دراستها
واصبحنا نعرف تماما ماذا يوجد في باطن
الارض
وما هي القوى القوه المحركه
للصفائح التكتونيه نتكلم عنها وهي متحركه
مهم جدا هذه هذا الشرح ماذا تحدث الزلازل
لماذا تحدث الزلازل نعم اذا كان عندك
متابعه فيما كنت اقوله تفضل بس يعني كسبا
للوقت معك لكي نستفيد من وجودك اعود الى
يعني اذا كان في جواب واضح على السؤال هل
يمكن ان نعرف تماما اذا كان ما حصل هزه
ارتداديه او زلزال جديد كيف يمكن ان نفرق
والى اين مدى يمكن ان يستمع ذلك
هناك مراصد هذا المرصد
يعتمد على نحن بنسميه
جسم ثقيل
متدلي وفي بنهايته قلم يرسم على ورق يتحرك
بسرعه محدده هذا الجسم الثقيل عندما يحدث
الزلزال فهو
يرسم هذه التموجات على ورق هناك منه نوعين
من هم من يعمل بشكل
افقي ومنهم من يعمل بشكل عمودي فهذه هذه
التسجيلات مثل مثل ضربات القلب التي
نسجلها هذه تسمح بمقارنه هذا الزلزال وذاك
الزلزال يعني هذا يعني
يعني عندما عندما يحدث زلزال يسجله المرصد
انه هذا الزلزال جديد
وثلاث اربع مراصد حوالين الموقع الزلزال
الجديد يعني هذا الحدث هنا المرصد سجله
بعد بعد خمس دقائق
سجله بالساعه الفلانيه يعني فينا نقيس
قديش السرعه وانت وصل له المرصد الثالث
المرصد الرابع في التقاطع هذه المعلومات
تسمح بتحديد موقع الزلزال بالفعل موقع
الزلزال بالفعل هلا التسجيل الزلزالي
بالموقع هذا التسجيل يسمح برؤيه التباعدات
بين الخطوط ويسمح
باخذه الى مقياس ريختر يعني زلزال الذي
فيه تباعد هالقد كبير وزلزال هالقد
وزلزالك كل كل قياس هذه الوحده التي نراها
على يسمح بتقدير تقدير
مدى الطاقه التي التي ادت اليك فالدكتور
اذا ما عندي اذا ما عندي تسجيل بالمرصد ما
عندي تسجيل لهذا ارتداديه اذا ما في تسجيل
بالمسد بتكون ارتداديه والا بكون زلزال
مؤكد بحسب طبيعه الرصد اللي تحدثت عنه
عظيم
اللي عم بيقولوا هاجر الطبيعي يعني عادي
التوقع بهالمجال وانه يحدد من 20 الى 22
فبراير وانه ممكن تكون الذروه او هو غير
طبيعي في علم الجيولوجيا خاصه بموضوع
الزلازل اخي
يقولون عالم هولندي هو عالم عالم بشوه
منه جيولوجي ولا ايدولوجي ولا عنده
مختبرات ولا ولا حدا سامع عن اشغاله او
اعماله البحثيه او الى اخره فهو عالم بشو
هو يقول بان النجوم والهدت هي التي تحرك
تحرك الصفائح التكتونيه الشمس لا تحرك
صفائح تكتونيه ثقيله موجوده على سطح الكره
الارضيه يعني قاره افريقيا قله
القمر الشمس تيجي تحركها يعني لو فيها
تحرك شيء الشمس كتحرك الغلاف الجوي او
الكتله المائيه الموجوده هناك
يعني كلامه لا يستقيم ولا باي شكل مع
الجيولوجيا انه هناك هناك كل شيء على سطح
الارض هو مختلف تماما عما يوجد تحت باطن
الارض ما يحرك باطن الارض هي المواد
النوويه الملتهبه المشتعله التي تنتج طاقه
حراريه رهيبه التي تنتج
صهاره متحركه تتحرك
الصدام بين هذه الكتله المائيه للسائله
المتحركه مع الصخور تنتج موجات زلزاليه
ثلاث انواع من موجات الذريه التي تخرج من
مكان الاصطدام لتصل الى سطح الارض بين
الصفائح يعني بالفراغات الموجوده بين
الصفائح او عبر
الكسور لا تنتج زلازل الكسور هي نتيجه
لمرور موجات زلزاليه عبر الصقر وممارسه
الضغط الضغط هو الذي كسر الصخر وبين
الزلازل وبين الفوارق هذا
يعتبره طبيعي حضرتك وقد يستمر ويجب ان
يتاقلم الناس
بعد يعيشون فيها
نعم الشيء المستغرق يعني الشيء اللي انا
رايته شويه هيك انه الطاقه الرهيبه التي
خرجت بالزلزال الاول
بالزلزال الاول الذي حدثه عم تقوله انه
زلزلان هلا هون زلزلين ممكن يعني في مراصد
لقت انه في في مركزين يعني في في مركزين
طلع منهم الطاقه الهيد طلعت من محلين عم
بتقول بغازي عنتاب
تانيه صحيح وفي مسافه بيناتهم فاذا هناك
مخرجين يعني مش طابقه رهيبه مختزنه موجوده
هذا شيء جديد والقوه الزلزال يعني قوه 7.7
مقياس الاخضر شيء جديد يمكن على الساحه
التركيه التي هي نشطه زلزاليه ولكن لم تصل
الى هذا الحد والشاي الاخر هذا انه بعد
فتره
لا ادري كم يوم طلعت الزلزتين اول امبارح
البارحة صحيح
اللي طلعوا ولو اقل اقل حده من الزلزال
الاول هذا يعني ان هناك بقايا من الطاقه
التي لها خرجت تاخرت في الخروج وربما في
هذا شيء جيد لانه الزلزال الاول مع كل
الدمار اللي صار سبع الفتره الزمنيه سمحت
لعمال لغاسه يعني انقاذ الناس انقاذ وسمحت
ايضا بخروج كل المواطنين من بيوتهم
ومتصدعه تفسيرك لما اقول انه
اثار تساؤلك قليلا
استاذ في علم الجيولوجيا وتقول انه اثار
تساؤلات عندك من حيث لا قوه الزلزال الاول
حجم الطاقه
نعم هل مره صار من اربع مراكز يعني عده
زلزالين جداد كمان صار اربع مرات انه مش
شيء غير غير مالوف مش انه غير طبيعي ما
نراه شيء طبيعي الارض الارض تخرج الطاقه
الموجوده من المحتبسه فيها واخرجتها
وارتاحت لان لان بقاء هذه الطاقه تحت
ستنتظر الفرصه لترجع وتنفجر من جديد تمام
بعد بعد الانفجار والهزات والزلازل
المفروض ترتاح الارض ويلزمها وقت قديش
يعني وقت لا ادري كم حتى
تيجي تقولها يعني اخر زلزال صار بهذه
المنطقه ايمتى اي سنه ونشوف هيدا الزلزال
هلا انه على نفس الخط الزلزالي طبعا
الاناضول انه في ولا زلزال سبعه او شيء
طيب انت حدث هذا حدث بسنه كذا من سنه كذا
لسنه كذا فينا نعرف تقريبا قديش الوقت حتى
تتجمع الطاقه من جديد وحتى ترجع تطلع
وتنفجر شكرا جزيلا لك هذا الميكانيس من
اللي
له اساس علمي اللي له اساس علمي علم
الزلازل المتطوره وعلم جيولوجي كتير
متطورين انا اشكر وجودك معنا استاذ سمير
زعاطيطي الاستاذ فيولوجيا من بيروت تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادره للعربيه بان اهداف الغارات
الاسرائيليه الاخيره على سوريا شملت
مستودعين يعودان الى علي عساف الناشط
السابق في حزب الله وقاعده لوجستيه تابعه
لفيلق القدس بالاضافه الى مستودع كبير
[__] ادوات هندسيه يستخدمها فيلق القدس
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا بيربوك
بحكم الايران بالاعدام بحق الايراني
الالماني
ووصفته بغير المقبول وتوعدت برد قوي ان
مضى الطهران في تنفيذ الحكم وكان القضاء
الايراني دانا شارماهد بما يعرف بتهمه
الفساد في الارض
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
كان اتهم ايران بالضلوع في محاولات اغتيال
معارضين لنظامها بالخارج
لقد راينا القمع المتجدده في شوارع ايران
ضد بعض المواطنين لمجرد محاولتهم التعبير
عن ارائهم ونرى ان ايران تقوم بمؤامرات
الاغتيال اولئك الذين يعارضون النظام في
دول اخرى بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده ما
زلنا نعتقد انه فيما يتعلق بالبرنامج
النووي فان الطريقه الاكثر فعاليه
واستدامه للتعامل مع التحدي الذي يفرضه هي
من خلال الدبلوماسيه لكن في هذه اللحظه
فان هذه الجهود متراجعه لكن الباب مفتوح
دائما امام الدبلوماسيه للمضي قدما وهذا
يعتمد على ما تقوله وتفعله ايران وما اذا
كانت تشارك ام لا
[موسيقى]
فالعربيه 360 ايضا في ايطاليا يقل الطلب
على القوارب فقد صارت البحيرات تقطع مشيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
يعني التنفي انها تحد من امدادات الذخيره
للمتطوعين على الجبهات القتاليه دون ان
تذكر فاغنر بالاسم
هذا رد من وزاره الدفاع للنقطه جدليه بعد
انتقادات فاجنر وبريجوجين القاسيه بحق
وزاره الدفاع اودعت السعوديه مليار دولار
في البنك المركزي اليمني مؤكده ان ذلك
ياتي في اطار حرص المملكه ودعمها المتواصل
لمسانده الشعب اليمني التنمويا واقتصاديا
وذكر بيان نشرته وكاله الانباء السعوديه
ان هذه الخطوه تؤكد وقوف المملكه الدائم
مع اليمن حكومه وشعبا وانه من المؤمل ان
تسهم في تعزيز القدرات بمجال تنفيذ برنامج
الاصلاح الاقتصادي وجهود بناء احتياطيات
هذا البنك المركزي اليمني لتمكينه من
تعزيز الاستقرار الاقتصادي
من جهته عبر رئيس مجلس القياده اليمني
رشاد العليمي عن شكره للسعوديه بعد
ايداعها مليار دولار في حساب البنك
المركزي اليمني وقال ان السعوديه صاحبه
رؤيه مسؤوله تجاه اليمن ولطالما ساندت
اقتصاد اليمن وخففت من معاناه شعبه
ايضا اشاد رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد
الملك بالوديعه السعوديه مؤكده انها ستدعم
جميع مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه واضاف عبد
الملك في تصريحات للعربيه ان الوديعه
السعوديه ستسهم في تحقيق الاستقرار النقدي
وستدعم قدرات البنك المركزي اليمني للوفاء
بالتزاماته واشار ايضا الى ان اليمن يواجه
تحديات كبيره في ظل التهديدات الارهابيه
للميليشيات
صوره اليوم من هطايا التركيه تجلس النساء
في انتظار ان يكمل الرجال المهمه جمع ما
يصلح من اثاث ومتاع لان القادم لن يكون
سهلا توفير منزل جديد في منطقه لم يبقى
فيها الكثير من المنازل او الانتقال
لمنطقه اخرى تكون فيها الارض اكثر
استقرارا تجلس النساء في شرود يسترجعن
السيناريو المؤلم كيف تغيرت الحياه بدقيقه
واحده يتمنين لو عاد الزمن قليلا للوراء
الى السادس من فبراير قبل الزلزال وسكن
هناك
في تصريح اليوم الصراع في اوكرانيا كلف
الاقتصاد العالمي
1.6 تريليون دولار في عام 2022 التصريح هو
لمعهد كولونيا للابحاث الاقتصاديه والذي
توقع ايضا ان يكلف الصراع في العام الحالي
تريليون دولار اخرى والاسباب عديده منها
انخفاض الانتاج وتعطيل سلاسل التوريد
وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه وما تبعها من دوره
جديده في ارتفاع معدلات التضخم وانخفاض
القوه الشرائيه والاسوا من هذا كله
اللامؤشرات حتى الان على نهايه هذا الصراع
وانما بات الحديث عن مخاوف من توسعه
اما فيديو اليوم فكابوس الجفاف الذي يعود
الى ايطاليا بعد ان انخفضت المياه في
بحيره جاردا شمال البلاد الى مستويات
قياسيه يتذكر الايطاليون ما حدث في الصيف
الماضي مع موجه جفاف كانت الاسوا في 70
عاما وبات لسان حالهم يقول الجفاف يلاحقنا
صيفا شتاء وما كنا نحتاج لقوارب كي نعبره
سنجتازه مشيا
الى صهيب شراير معه اخبار الساعه الان
ماذا لديك مساء الخير صهيب مساء الخير
طاهر لدينا مزيد من المتابعه حول مقالات
الصراع في اوكرانيا خاصه في ظل التصعيد
بين بايدن وبوتين وكذلك ما بعد الزلزلين
الجديدين في جنوب تركيا اليك تفضل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]